bonjour merci d'être avec nous alors
prestation de serment aujourd'hui
quelles seront les priorités pour le
nouveau premier ministre italien
oui aujourd'hui on a eu une première
réunion des des ministres avec nouveau
président du conseil
les objectifs principalement il est déjà
presque réussi c'est à dire de redonner
une certaine confiance pour l'économie
italienne au niveau européen bien sûr
mario draghi est une personne qui a
beaucoup travaillé en europe et pour
l'europe donc il a déjà apporté cette
réputation qui permet de rentabiliser le
niveau économique italien c'était le
premier objectif ensuite il va falloir
se mettre au travail
il ya une certaine curiosité on avait
des observateurs politiques en italie
parce que comment mario draghi va
réussir à travailler avec d'un nombre de
ministres 10 arrêts surtout de deux
bords politiques très différents il va
falloir faire travailler toutes ces
personnes ensemble et ça risque d'être
un petit peu compliqué pas mais c'est
vrai qu'on habille toi un grand écart au
niveau de ce nouveau gouvernement
italien justement que pouvez vous dire
quant au choix qu'a fait le nouveau
premier ministre
il ya des choix revient sur un toit
d'équité 1 puisque tous les partis qui
ont participé qui vont voter en faveur
de ce nouveau gouvernement ont des
ministres et d'une manière équitable
3 le parti de silvio berlusconi 3 pour
la lega de 5 min 3 pour le parti
démocrate
c'est à dire que chaque partie est
représentée de façon assez égale dont
les roule dans l'ensemble les personnes
qui ont été nommées sont des personnes à
ses experts tu as expérimentés la
moyenne d'âge est de 53 ans qui est
assez élevé mais pas trop quand même et
toutes les personnes quasiment toutes
les personnes de ce gouvernement qui ont
déjà eu un bol ou de ministres ou des
experts dans leur domaine avant donc on
a plutôt mario draghi a fait le choix de
prendre des personnes des valeurs sûres
ou à dire qui certainement pourront se
mettre au travail assez vite et être
assez efficace pour tout caler les
serbes
alors vous le disiez en mario draghi
n'est pas un inconnu en europe 1 il a
été président de la banque
centrale européenne est ce que c'est une
garantie en tant que nouveau premier
ministre pour relancer l'économie de
l'italie
clairement ça va forcément et délirer
point de vue symbolique déjà ensuite
justement cette équipe qu'il a dessiné
une équipe plutôt d'économistes en
général mais les personnes qu'il a
choisi dans les parties les plus
populistes
par exemple il a choisi monsieur
giorgetti comme ministre donc de la
relance économique qui est donc de la
ligue b qui est la partie la plus
modérée de la vie la partie plus ouverte
justement à l'économie et à l'union
européenne
donc il a choisi et dans l'ensemble des
personnes beaucoup plus orienté vers
bruxelles
c'est la grande différence il y avait
peut-être avec les gouvernements
précédents
on sent un désir de la part de monsieur
draghi de vos maîtres qui t'habille au
centre de l'europe et donc de permettre
de relancer l'économie au niveau
européen et au niveau de la politique
sanitaire est ce que selon vous il y
aura un changement de direction de cap
comparé à l'ancien gouvernement alors
sur ce point normalement il devrait pas
y avoir de changement drastique puisque
le ministre de la santé précédent est
reconduit dans ses fonctions c'est
toujours monsieur speranza qui va
s'occuper de cette stratégie
actuellement la stratégie opérée
fonctionne plutôt bien dans un système
régional chaque semaine il ya une
évaluation de chaque zone
la coordination avec les régions et même
avec les verts est de plus en plus
bonnes maintenant on reçoit un équilibre
vraiment bon peuple
l'efficacité il va falloir voir bien sûr
l'évolution du virus sur le territoire
il y a plusieurs foyers du virus venant
du royaume uni qui s'est mis au centre
de l'italie à l'occupant un petit peu
certaines parties sont tombées en
faisant une rouge pour refermer
alors que d'autres organes et des
libertés mais ce système flexible
régionales semble fonctionner pour
l'instant et donc tu vas continuer comme
ça et comment est vécue cette entrée en
fonction à du nouveau premier ministre
par le peuple par les italiens tout le
monde de curiosité ce qui est sûr c'est
que on va dire pour les italiens on sent
la valeur sûre d'une personne qui a une
autorité
de toute façon mais il ya énormément de
curiosité pour savoir comment il va
réussir à faire travailler toutes ses
pertes
un ensemble j'en parlais avec les
italiens hier c'était la vraie question
comment faire travailler les personnes
de bord très différents qui se sont
parfois opposé pendant des années vous
avez le parti démocrate avec des
personnes qui ont été opposés pendant 20
ans à sédhiou berlusconi qui aujourd'hui
vont travailler avec le parti ce double
obstrué ça va être très difficile de
trouver les 5 millions à l'intérieur du
gouvernement
mais je pense que beaucoup sont
confiants par rapport à l'autorité de
mario draghi et sa capacité justement de
faire son travail et de consort taux des
taxes
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
fabien gilot je rappelle que vous êtes
enseignant à l'université ne tuera
remercie